yo it's your buddy josh can't wait for
you to check out this clip
it's from a special that i shot over
quarantined in front of a
socially distanced masked 20-person
crowd so if you can't hear the crowd
imagine how i felt love this material
can't wait for you to check it out watch
the whole special
father time later everybody i didn't
give
my kids bandage drill one night and i
was having sex with uh
she's here uh i'm talking about you uh
having sex with my wife and things are
going very well
and i felt this finger touch my ass
now listen when you're married and a
finger touches your ass you're like okay
is is that what we're doing tonight like
because
married sex is regular you have regular
sex and every now and then somebody has
too many drinks he's like let's try this
and you're like
you're always like i didn't know we were
doing i had a [ __ ] shower if i knew
we were doing that tonight you know what
i mean like
is this what's going down tonight yeah
and plus there's no way she's touching
my ass she was handcuffed
but um so
i turn around and we see it's our
youngest son jacob and he's at the end
of the bed he's probably three and a
half at the time
and oh and um he's he's sitting there
and he's doing this
you know that age when they did that and
beth just pulls the covers over her head
and she goes
handle it so
i she's under the covers that means i'm
out of the covers
and i'm just at the end of the bed just
dick out just
hey buddy you know
and he was just sitting there and he was
going he was like
and by the way jacob has always stood
like forrest gump i have no idea what
this dude's always been like hey
lieutenant like i have no idea this is
always
so he's standing there and he goes what
are you doing
and i said uh telling mom jokes
and everybody has their thing that you
tell your kids when they walk in on you
you know what i mean some people like
i'm giving your mom a back rub i'm
cleaning your mom's face whatever it is
[Applause]
[Laughter]
sorry about that he's never said that to
your mom just other people's moms you
know
and so uh no he didn't say that to other
people's moms either you know what i'm
gonna stop talking to you guys
um so i go and by the way i'd always say
i'm
telling your mom jokes because he would
ask me what do you do for a living and
i'd be like well i tell jokes and he'd
go oh
do people laugh i'm like yeah people
laugh is it is it
is it good when people laugh yeah it's
good when people laugh oh
so he goes uh what are you doing
i said i'm telling mom jokes and he goes
she's not laughing i mean well she was
before you came in
and he goes this was my favorite part he
just looks at me
up and down naked still dick out and
just goes
you're silly and just walks out of the
room
so and by the way people watching and i
know there are a lot of
kids watching with their parents and
you're here thank god so i can say this
and make you guys uncomfortable
here's something you need to know and
look deep into my eyes kids i know
you're sitting next to your parents
here's something you need to know
your parents [ __ ] here's the deal here's
what you need to know your parents your
parents
they [ __ ] and your mom i'm not saying
about your mom your mom's a good mom
but she's a bad girl you know what i'm
saying
your mom cuts the crust off your
sandwich but she's also been like this
with your dad's junk stop it stop doing
that
it's not funny anymore stop that you
know what i mean
so there's a lot of things you don't
know about your parents
we tell you something else you don't
know about your parents you know what
they they don't know
what the [ __ ] they're doing when the the
thing you realize the most when you
become a parent
is you like oh my parents had no idea
what the [ __ ] was happening
they just made and they're watching so
but um they just made things up as they
went you know and we
we'd do the same thing with you guys um
so i thought by the way i thought okay
he saw me he said walked in but we're
gonna be fine he hasn't mentioned
anything you know
and then we were out at the park and uh
and by the way
when he left the room i said to beth i'm
like
we're still having sex right
she goes no jacob was just in here i'm
like
yeah but he's he's not here now
she was like no and i go are you sure
she goes
i'll just lay here and i was like okay
i think i think it's funny that women
think that's a deal breaker when they're
like fine i'll just lay here
every guy's like that's cool i'm on
board for that you're just gonna
you're saying yes but you're gonna be
still cool no problem with that at all
[Applause]
yeah
that is not a deal breaker at all i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna lay here
and it's so funny i tried to i tried to
tell her that like
it just shows you how attracted i am to
you and she's like
all i hear is that you would [ __ ] a tree
and i'm like well that too but
i don't want to say no to the tree out
of hand that seems mad you know
so jakey and i at the park and um
he comes up to me and he goes
i know what you tell for jokes and i go
you do
and by the way he used to ask me what do
you tell for jokes and i go what do you
think i tell for jokes
and you go i think you just do things
like this
and i'm like you're not that far off uh
yeah i mean you're in the ballpark at
least you know
and so he um he goes i know you tell for
jokes and i go
what and he goes well i know a joke you
should tell
i go tell me and he goes i think you
should tell that joke about your penis
sticking straight up
and we're at the park in public guys i'm
like hey man uh
inside voice bro you know what i'm
saying like uh i said what
he goes that joke about your penis
sticking straight up you should tell
people are going to laugh
i'm going no no he's going to laugh at
that man he goes i did i laughed a lot
and i was like first of all [ __ ] you uh
that's not nice
but he became obsessed
obsessed with my junk
like he just could not stop any time he
got a chance
like i was coming out of the shower once
and it was at that age where you know
the kid might be a little too scared to
go in the shower by himself so you kind
of cross paths and you wait in the
bathroom with him on he takes a shower
and we were crossing paths
and he just started staring at my junk
just
and i went for the towel and he goes no
no no no no
wait a second i grabbed the towel and i
was like first of all dude
don't squint what are you squinting at
that is not a nice thing to do
and he said your your penis is bigger
than mine
and you know what folks no matter how
the other person is
it's always nice to hear that you know
what i mean like i i didn't know i
needed to hear it i was like you're a
good son i
i really like that you know
[Applause]
but by the way i want to tell you guys
and this is the kind of comedy nerd [ __ ]
that i kind of want to get into here
so there was a story i told about jacob
walking in on us
and i'm going to tell you how i used to
tell it um
i'm going to tell you how i used to tell
it my wife and i are having sex
and i feel a finger touch my ass and i'm
thinking
what i [ __ ] marry houdini like you
know what i mean like she's a magician
you know
and i turn around as my youngest son and
uh
i didn't know what to do but i'm no
quitter you know so i just decided i was
gonna pull the jedi mind trick on him
and i just stood in front of him like
there's nothing to see here
that's not my day
and i thought i was fine he went off
into his bedroom
until career day at his school
when the teacher said come on up here
jacob tell us who your daddy does
[Music]
my dad is a comedian he makes people
laugh
teacher said tell something funny or
daddy does he goes okay my daddy can
make his penis stick straight up show
him daddy
and i was like all right i don't know
how funny it's gonna be but uh
okay so the reason i changed that joke
and i'll tell you why
is one of the stories is true and one
isn't
as a young comic i just was not
confident to tell the real story i felt
like i needed to write punch lines
and it turns out the real story is
better
and it's one of the first it's one of
the first lessons of uh
truth in your art is just more appealing
to the people who are listening to it
man
it was it's a hard lesson to learn you
[Music]
know
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]